oh nothing x/t annex not another
next another NYX is an app that teaches
you how to be a castrato to mix your
nuts so that you can preserve your high
boyish singing voice surprisingly
popular I don't think that's a start-up
as I thought that's like a fiber cereal
isn't it yeah nut mix keeps you rec Anna
plan is listening you've been married
for a while and you're trying to sort of
take things to the next level and a plan
and a plan sort of teaches you how to
ease into anal play sprinkler a man or a
woman your preference for two or three
will come and pee on you
Twilio isn't it Twitter's fart at like
such a lazy Oh Twitter I just did a
Twilio oh man Lorna sure and his best
friend is kind of a about what she
does for a living I mean that's just my
aunt's name automatic with two T's is a
company run by a dude named Matt that's
actually true is it a guy named Matt and
it's the company that owns WordPress the
really form what a piece of
Tubber I don't know when you go to bin
I'm a member
moseyed oh that's how to make a muddled
drink but for the illiterate the app
teaches you how to do judo karate with
mozzarella let me suppose let me see I'm
just let me select gusto formerly known
as zenpayroll but they changed it with
gusto to an equally useless name Tubber
TJ Miller is not only a member he's the
president cabbage it's the official food
of the KKK that one's an acronym it
stands for right killing all baby boys
and gaining energy it's war it's a kind
of a goblin based app oh yeah wired
that's like a GQ for the sexually an
adventurous a magazine for people who
like tech and don't know any other
better magazines to buy up it's like
it's like a men's health for for virgins
don't up click a link somewhere
around here